Film Courage: I’d love to hear your thoughts
on risk and failure?
Tosca Musk, Director, Producer and CoFounder
of Passionflix: Whoo!
Yeah, thoughts on risk and failure.
I think both are vital.
So I think you should continue to risk and
you will fail and when you do, you have to
get back up and you have to try again because
that’s the only way that you are going to
succeed.
And true failure is when you don’t get back
up afterward.
So failure is not continuing.
Failure is giving up.
So there is no option to fail.
Film Courage: So with failure do you think
it becomes like a muscle, say almost like
stage fright, where you go to Toastmasters
or something and you get better at it.
So with failure you’re maybe okay with it
more [often]?
You’ve developed tougher skin?
Because I’ve seen it in reverse where failure
really guts people and they don’t get back
up.
Tosca: Well, as I said, failure to me really
is not getting back up.
So that is ultimate failure.
Getting back up and continuing to do something
again, trying again, coming up with another
idea, another solution, is moving forward.
And that is risky and it’s hard and painful
sometimes.
But if you don’t get up and do it again,
then you’ve failed.
So there are a lot of examples of people who
have gotten up and tried again.
But most of the people who are successful
and have gotten up and tried again and continue
to try again and fail and if they fail again,
continue to try again and that means that
they haven’t failed.
Film Courage: City of Los Angeles, you say
that a lot of people who come here are risk
takers.
Do you feel that you were a risk taker when
you came?
Tosca: Did I say that people who come to Los
Angeles are risk takers?
Film Courage: I don’t know?
I’m trying to see from my notes if you did.
Maybe you did?
I don’t know if I just thought that?
Tosca: Well I think that if people are coming
to Los Angeles to be in the film industry
that is definitely taking a chance.
But you have a goal, you have a desire but
if you can remained focus which is very hard
especially in an industry that is filled with
rejection.
Constant, constant rejection in every industry.
But if you can continue in it, you will be
successful.
You just have to stay focused and keep trying,
keep trying, keep trying, keep trying, and
ultimately you will get that job.
I mean you have to be good, so keep working
at your skill.
Film Courage: Sure, sure.
I think it’s difficult too because no one
usually gives you notes on why you didn’t
get it.
I mean sometimes they do, but oftentimes they
don’t.
And it’s all across the board for whatever
it is [in this industry].
So there are not script notes where someone
is saying “We like you but…”
You don’t know what it was.
Tosca: And it is actually quite difficult
coming from the filmmaker’s standpoint (my
side of things) because I watch a lot of auditions
and we make decisions.
And mother mother is also a model so I come
from that world where she constantly goes
through rejection and has for her entire life.
And while she’s a very successful model,
she is rejected continually.
So I’ve been able to watch that and see
how she keeps going “Okay, next!
Okay, next!”
And then from my side of things (as the director)
“Well you might be good, but you don’t
look the part.”
And so I can’t hire you.
So initially it’s all…it’s so subjective
and so if I then get an agent who comes back
to me and says “Can you give me feedback?”
Which many times they do, if I can give feedback
I will.
But keep in mind if I audition 200 people,
I can’t give feedback for 200 people.
I don’t have that kind of time.
So it’s not that I didn’t like you.
Very likely, if you were in a room auditioning
for me, there is something about you that
I like.
And so you’ve made it there, well done.
Congratulations to you.
Keep going.
You are in the room.
So you made it there.
That should be acknowledgment enough that
while you didn’t get the part, there were
200 people who were going for this same part
as you.
And only one of you can get it.
So 199 people will be rejected.
But 199 people still made it into the room,
I still recognize them.
There are a couple of actors that I go every
single movie “Let’s see if we can put
them in this role?
On, no.
It’s not going to work unfortunately.”
And so they are contacted constantly and told
“Hey maybe you will be in this role.”
And then they’re not.
And it’s not anything other than it could
be timing, it could be, hair color, it could
be eye color.
It could be the author wasn’t a big fan.
It could be you’re too tall for the female
actor.
Or too short for the female actor or you know
what I mean?
There are so many different aspects that go
into it that have nothing to do with your
ability to perform.
So that’s why I say to actors keep going,
keep doing it!